China's wall against a second wave three
million people in Beijing have been
tested over the last two weeks when an
outbreak started in wholesale food
market in the south of the city
authorities have this ready to go the
procedure and process were prescribed
and we followed them strictly we're just
a number of staff accordingly this
Center was built in just a day and a
half because this isn't just about scale
it's about speed of thought and then of
action there's no point
permanently maintaining infrastructure
like this when there are no covert 19
cases instead authorities quickly
recognized they had a sustained outbreak
than added capacity they set up testing
centers all around the city some more
chaotic than others that approach means
Beijing has been able to avoid going
into full problem based on the principle
of timely identification swift control
precise prevention and effective
treatment the testing work targeting key
areas and key populations across the
city has been conducted Beijing has
contained the outbreak that's why the
government has invited us here to film
to show the world just how well they're
doing
China's initial response to covert 19
when it started in Wuhan was
catastrophic a cover-up and a bungle all
this is meant to show how it's developed
a playbook since then a playbook the
rest of the world should be learning
from testing is one part but contact
tracing is just as vital here Beijing
relies on technology and it doesn't ask
permission early this month snow jang
got stuck in the traffic jam on her way
back from ikea i'm known to her she was
six kilometers away from the market at
the center of the outbreak authorities
access to her location data from her
mobile phone network tracked her down
and made her take a covert 19 tests on
the personal level i feel a bit weird
but looking at the bigger picture big
data' does
really have substantial consequences for
me reminding me to do the test and
reminding me of my travel history
looking back the benefits outweigh the
drawbacks Beijing thinks it's got the
job done at this time but this is shift
work without a vaccine and with each new
flare-up they'll have to do this over
and over again
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing